et on va parler bien sûr encore de cette
rentrée des classes de la BAA une jeune
adolescente de 14 ans c'est refuser
l'entré en classe car elle portait un
kimono elle était en 4e comme je vous
l'ai dit comprenez-vous ces exclusions
comment définir ce qui est une abaya
estce qui n'est pas alors je vais vous
dire ça déjà ça va être un bordel mon je
va vous dire il faut maintenant il faut
des stylistes à l'entrée des
établissements non mais ça comment
comment on sait c'est je vous dis ça ça
va être un bordel pas possible et je
crois que ça peu de gens l'avaient
anticipé regardez petit récap et son
papa sera avec nous également dans un
instant qui va nous dire ce qui s passé
vous allez voir la la photo de comment
elle est habillée et son papa veut la
défendre ce soir dans TPMP c'est
parti c'est le sujet brûlant de cette
rentrée laba qui est un vêtement
religieux et donc prohibé je ne savais
pas que labaya est un un signe religieux
depuis que Gabriel hatal a annoncé
l'interdiction à l'école de cette robe
longue qui couvre le corps certaines
adolescentes dénoncent des dérives dans
cette restriction une lycéenne a été
exclue de son lycée car elle portait un
kimono une exclusion suivie par d'autres
dont celle de cet élève de 4 renvoyé
pour avoir à son tour porté ce kimono
rose un vêtement ample d'origine
japonaise le père de la collégienne qui
crée aujourd'hui à la discrimination
s'exprime ce soir dans TPMP alors
comprenez-vous la décision du chef
d'établissement et oui Gilan merci
d'être avec nous merci votre fille n'a
pas pu entrer en classe cette semaine
parce qu'elle portait cette tenue
j'aimeris que dans le débat on reste sur
cette tenue voilà qu'on commence pas à
aller chercher le sujet en général puis
qu'on en a déjà parl cette tenue a été
refusée est-ce que vous comprenez hein
est-ce que vous comprenez la décision de
l'établissement est-ce qu'on peut mettre
la question s'il vous plaît Karim Zeribi
et Eric nolo sont avec nous pour cette
cette BRI une adolescente de 4e renvoyé
de son collège car elle portait un
kimono la question s'il vous plaît c'est
important pour les téléspectateurs
comprenez-vous la décision de
l'établissement euh Éric nolo vous la
comprenez je la comprends parfaitement
parce que cette oui parce qu'il y a des
problèmes très graves en ce moment à
l'éducation nationale il y a la lutte
contre l'islamisme vous avez vu que le
Conseil d'État a validé l'interdiction
de la BAA et il y a le problème du
harcèlement vous avez vu qu'un gamin de
15 ans s'est pendu et il y a un
troisième problème c'est l'effondrement
du niveau scolaire que ça soit celui des
élèves ou des professeurs et selon moi
il y a des problèmes dérisoires et parmi
les problèmes dérisoires je classe les
états d'âes d'une collégi par rapport à
sa tenue si l'établissement décide que
sa tenue n'est pas adéquate la décision
s'impose votre fille mais je dis votre
fille parce qu'on parle d'elle mais ça
ça vaut évidemment pour tout le monde je
ne personnalise pas le débat peut porter
ce kimono chez elle peut porter ce
kimono dans la rue peut le porter où
elle veut sauf à l'école où c'est le
chef d'établissement qui va décider donc
écoutez maintenant il faut arrêter
d'encombrer l'actualité avec des faux
problèmes des faux sujets et se
concentrer sur ce que j'ai dit la lutte
contre l'islamisme la lutte contre le le
le le harcèlement et le relèvement du
niveau scolaire tout le reste c'est
dérisoire c'est un Odin ça ne fait
qu'encombrer l'actualité et nous
empêcher de réfléchir voilà pourquoi je
suis favorable il va vous répondre dans
inst je soutiens la décision de
l'établissement il va vous répondre dans
un instant Karim c'est RBI ben je trouve
qu'É N a dit une seule chose
d'intéressante dans son propos c'est
qu'il fallait c'est qu'il
fallait s'attacher au sujet prioritaire
exement et c'est le seul point sur
lequel nous serons d'accord et en
l'occurrence une jeune fille qui arrive
avec une tunique de pièces euh comme on
peut en trouver donc de partout je ne
vois pas en quoi cela contrevient au
principe de laïité et je le précise
auquel je tiens car je trouve important
que les principes de laïité soient
respectés que les signes religieux soit
reste à l'extérieur qui pas croit voile
donc je suis un défenseur de l'école
publique et laïque mais là je trouve
qu'on verse dans le délire on verse dans
le délire parce que je ne vois pas en
quoi cette tenue a une une quelconque
référence avec le religieux et donc je
trouve qu'on ouvre une boîte de Pandore
qui devient dangereuse avec une forme de
stigmatisation discrimination à quoi
va-t-on décider qu'une tenue est
acceptable ou pas est-ce que c'est au
faciess de jeunes filles est-ce que si
une blonde donc fa européen porte cette
tenue est-ce qu'on va lui dire qu'elle
n'est pas acceptable j'en doute fort moi
je vous le dis sur ça sur ça sur ça je
suis assez d'accord a to parce que même
la couleur et tout je je vois pas le je
comprends pas en fait exact et je vous
le dis je suis d'autant plus choqué que
avanthier on a une nouvelle encore
catastrophique dans le pays un jeune de
15 ans s'est pendu oua à poissie en
raison du harcèlement scolaire il y a
850000 gamins qui sont victimes de
harcèlement scolaire dans notre pays il
y a eu 68 cas d'abaya à la rentrée
scolaire on nous a fait du abaya matin
midi et soir une semaine avant la
rentrée scolaire et ben il y a pas eu de
problème donc curieusement parce que les
filles ne sont pas là pour créer de
soucis elles veulent étudier trouver
leur place à la société elles ne sont
pas le bras des Islam islamiste vous
parlez d'une offensive islamiste avec 28
filles sur 12 millions d'étudiants non
mais il faut qu'on arrête le délire il
faut qu'on revienne à l'essentiel il y a
des gamins 6e qui savent pas lire il y a
850000 gamins qui sont victimes de
harcèlement il y a 160000 gamins qui
sont victimes d'inceste et vous allez me
parler d'une tenue de pièces qu'on
trouverait dans tous les magasins et que
toutes les jeunes filles peuvent porter
on est dans le délire il faut que ce
délire s'arrête il faut qu'on revienne à
l'essentiel aux priorités les priorité
c'est que ces filles puissent étudier
tranquillement comme les autres sans
être poincé du doigt et qu'on abandonne
un petit peu cette forme d'hystérie
autour de l'islam et des musulmans
laissez-les tranquillees les musulmans
qui sont pas d'accord avec on va les
avoir dans un
inst votre répon
sur bien sûr ouais bien sû j'ai eu
l'impression quand Cyril vous a demandé
est-ce que vous étiez d'accord avec la
décision d'interdire cette tenue j'ai
pas eu l'impression que vous avez
regardé la en fait j'ai l'impression que
quelle que soit la la photo qui va vous
montrer donc pour vous c'est pas
important vous serez d'accord avec la
décision vous savez on me l'a envoyé en
début d'après-midi la photo vous savez
il y a un minimum de préparation dans
cette émission donc j'ai eu le temps
quand
même monsieur nolo oui c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit un minimum franchement tous les
deux on regarde vous faites un mauvais
procès ça commence mal pardon vous me
faites un mauvais procès ça commence
mal pour vous donc pour vous c'est
association c'est associé à une tenue
islamique comme ça je vous dis
simplement que la décision du chef
d'établissement
s'impose à une collégienne de 14 ans
c'est comme ça que ça marche dans la vie
votre fille je dis votre fille toute
fille peut faire ce qu'elle veut en
dehors de l'école là il y a une décision
est- il y a un lien avec la religion
c'est la question qui t''est posée tu
vois un lien là écoutez je je moi je
vais pas parce que il faut arrêter je
précise que ma fille elle a jamais été
voilée donc donc elle a jamais été
voilée donc elle a jamais eu de de souci
à l'école par rapport à ça donc moi je
aujourd'hui je parle par rapport à ce
qui est arrivé à c'est
ça trouve trs Janie est-ce qu'elle
allait en abaya à l'école avant jamais
de la vie il a elle a jamais eu de souci
par rapport à ça en fait je euh ben je
vais vous dire un truc tout simple ma
fille elle a reçu cette tenue comme
cadeau il y a au cours de l'été donc
elle a reçu deux tenues comme ça elle
était elle était contente elle était
affolée elle nous a montré
donc et euh
donc c'est c'est une mode c'est une
nouvelle mode il lui a dit
le proviseur B le proviseur il lui a dit
que sa tenue elle était assimilée une
ABA une donc et excusez-moi monsieur je
vais préciser ma pensée à partir du
moment il va y avoir des centaines de
cas comme ça
ambigus pas vous qui allit la trancher
c'est pas moi qui vais la trancher c'est
le chef d'établissement qui le chef
d'établissement lui demande d'enlever je
veux dire d'enlever le haut pour pouvoir
rentrer alors qu'elle avait un débardeur
en dessous je veux dire de quel de quel
droit de quel droit le chef de de
l'établissement marche sur la tête he
voilà il lui demande d'enlever et il m'a
appelé c'est-à-dire on m'a appelé il a
laissé un message à ma femme c'est c'est
c'est urgent il faut que vous appelez
tout de suite j'ai un problème j'ai
votre fille en ma présence il y a un
problème concernant votre mais ça a pris
des proportions énormes c'estutre chose
moi j'ai reçu un appel j'étais au boulot
je reçois un appel du du proviseur donc
il se présente je suis le viseur bah
heureusement que heureusement que c'est
pas ma femme qui l'a reçu ce ce ce coup
de téléphone donc donc je suis assez
calme mais mais je me suis inquiété je
me suis dit il arrivé un truc à ma fille
non c'est pas autre chose c'est le
délire concr et là il m'annonce que ma
fille en sa présence c'est que il me
parle d'abaya mais je lui dis mais mais
ma fille elle a jamais eu d'abaya elle
il me parle d'abaya tout ça mais je
comprenais pas il me dit il il
m'explique qu' lui a demandé de
l'enlever elle a pas voulu donc en fait
j'ai rien compris j'ai rien compris pour
moi une abaya c'est une c'est une tenue
complète et comment si on enlève
qu'est-ce qu'on a en dessous j'ai rien
compris en faitc vous êtes d'accord avec
Éric n oui moi je suis d'accord avec le
la décision du chef d'établissement
parce que j'ai constaté qu'il y avait eu
plusieurs incidents qui ont été signalés
en France et moi je vois tout ça comme
une forme de défi lancé à la décision
d'un ministre alors ce n'est peut-être
pas la motivation de votre fille
monsieur je vais aller jusqu'au bout
puisque vous dites qu'elle a jamais
porter la BA mais on a reçu lundi un
responsable islamique important et qui
lui-même a dit qu'il allait réagir et
que sa fille porterait le kimono dans
les jours qui suivent et il y a eu
d'autres cas qui ont été signalés mais
peut-être que la motivation mais
attendez si vous voulez pas est-ce que
est-ce que je peux préciser ma pensée
justement pour éviter les amalgames je
m'interroge sur la tactique qui est
utilisée pourquoi à partir du moment où
il y a une interdiction on dit non mais
on va porter des mouvements des des des
des vêtements amples on va porter un
kimono qu'est-ce qu'il cherche attendez
on a bien vu par le passé qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y a des
interdictions derrière il y a une
motivation de créer le désordre de créer
un précédent de faire en sorte
qu'ensuite on tombe sur un juge qui soit
finalement d'accord avec et voilà et on
va encore tomber dans des appréciations
un peu entre deux non il y a il y a une
règle il y a une règle arrêtons avec
cette histoire le kimono
c'est l'interprétation de la règle
justement vu ça va être un bordel
monstre ils vont créer quoi une sorte de
Kimo à BAA c'est ça c'est c'est l'idée
qui est derrière alors moi aussi la la
seule chose avec laquelle je suis
d'accord avec Éric c'est sa première
partie c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation il y a des choses beaucoup
beaucoup plus graves et à chaque fois on
passe tous les sujets très grave sous
silence pour des petites brouties et on
en fait tout un truc ici ce n'est
absolument pas religieux c'est une tenue
bon ben c'est une tenue qui se trouve
dans le commerce c'est très joli alors
dans le temps moi é contente de sa robe
pourquoi elle aurait pas la liberté de
poser sa robe sans des théories donc des
tactiques des théories colège justement
pour rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
j'ai été une fois renvoyé parce que
j'avais des bretelles trop fines et une
autre fois parce qu'on voyait un peu le
parce qu'on voyait un peu le ventre donc
chez nous c'était on a eu les mêm même
chose chez nous c'était les bretelles
larges ou mais bien sûr ou alors on
voyait pas le ventre donc que le
proviseur et demandé carrément à votre
fille d'enlever euh et donc du coup on
VO é indcente voilà à la rigueur si on
voit trop de peau effectivement je
comprends que ça puisse déranger les
garçons parce que moi c'est ce qu'on
m'avait dit mais si si une jeune fille
est trop couverte d'une manière je je
vois pas pourquoi ça dérangeer bah
justement elle est trop couverte pour
lui elle est trop couverte mais le
problème il m'expliquait que le problème
c'est qu'elle était trop couverte je
dire elle est la bille elle était trop
ample B à un moment je sais il faut
qu'on les laisse tranquilles ces pauvres
filles en fait est lativation attendez
on va se retrouver dans un instant les
ché on va se retrouver dans un
instant de porter une porter çaan et
Jacques c'est bon on va se retrouver
dans un instant les Chéries on va finir
là-dessus et puis on va voir donc
Jacques frimond euh donc vice-président
de l'Association pour la promotion du
naturisme en liberté qui sera avec nous
c'est pas pareil c'est de la transition
ça c'est de la transition un méti quand
sont magnifi un sacré
métier